recessions usually mean job losses
and when a recession begins to end we
typically see jobs start to open up
again
after all that's what happened after the
great recession in 2008. notably women
made up a large percentage of those who
entered the workforce during that
economic recovery period
after the great financial crisis in 2008
because family finances were so strained
a lot of women
entered the workforce to support their
families when they hadn't been doing so
before and at the same time we had a
really really strong labor market which
allowed women to enter who hadn't been
doing so up until early 2020 women were
making gains for you know the prior five
years
women's labor force participation had
been growing over the past 60 years in
fact things were going so well that in
january 2020 two months before the
coronavirus pandemic shut down the u.s
women had outpaced men as the majority
of the workforce for the first time in a
decade and this is a really good thing
because this is the future of the
workforce we are increasingly becoming a
services oriented economy
but all of that progress is wiped out
when the pandemic forced everyone home
disproportionately affecting women
around the world more than 12 million
women lost their jobs during the
pandemic and over four and a half
million have not returned to the
workforce
the impact of covet is so severe that it
set the rate of u.s female workforce
participation back more than 30 years to
the same rate it was in april 1987. so
while the 2008 recession recovery may
have worked out for many women this time
women are find themselves burnt out from
juggling unemployment or working
full-time remotely with domestic roles
many have even decided to give up their
careers entirely to tend to at home
unpaid labor and their own personal
health the burden of
caregiving
with schools and daycare still not fully
open in some parts of the country
is an added burden especially on mothers
so as businesses reopen and employers
are hiring again many women aren't
necessarily coming back in a crisis that
some economists are calling the first
female recession
out in california two of the best
mechanics working on linked trainer
planes are women it used to be during
recessions that women actually entered
the workforce to take care of their
families we saw the same after world war
ii and so this was a really unique
situation and that rather than joining
the workforce to support their families
they left the workforce to support their
families according to data from mckinsey
more than double the number of mothers
found themselves taking on an additional
five hours of daily domestic work
compared to their male counterparts much
of this can be attributed to gender
norms across societies with women
bearing more of the burden at home we
know that when there's a crisis at home
whether that's a pandemic or a family
crisis or a crisis with a child
themselves it's often women that are the
ones to
take on that care and so when we had
these school closures and daycare
closures it naturally was women that
left the workforce at a faster pace
what's different about this particular
recession is that it also affected women
across all pay levels from minimum wage
workers to high level executives i spoke
with a woman for some of my reporting
who was a top executive at facebook who
left her job for child care when you're
at such a high executive role like that
you can't just go and start working at a
bar which is really where the jobs are
open and when you have a competitive
resume it takes more time to re-enter
and so she was expecting it could take
up to six months or more to kind of get
the role that she was looking for other
women who chose to stay in the workforce
say they were barely hanging on while
balancing multiple full-time roles
reshma saljani is the ceo of the
organization girls who code at the
height of the pandemic she found herself
overwhelmed with juggling household
chores caring for her sons and working
on her non-profit remotely i was doing
the homeschooling while i was running my
organization in between i was doing the
laundry you know i mean doing the dishes
right ordering whatever i needed on
amazon
and so by the end of the day i was just
done you know i got covered and it
barely registered you know my liver
failed i had acne on my face as if i was
like 16 years old and it wasn't just me
in response to the pandemic reshma is
proposing a marshall plan to better
support working moms including wage
equity paid family leave and work
retraining programs when women return
from maternity leave you know moms are
not america's social safety net we're
one of the few countries that doesn't
offer a paternity allowance that's come
today in the form of a child tax credit
today the expanded child tax credit is
here but that was a revolutionary idea
that's been met with a tremendous amount
of resistance
as a mother a single mother like you
need to be there
for everything for your child i was
working at 3-1-1 i got a call
it was like an emergency call
and my supervisor like you can't use
your phone so if people need you they
have to call like the office and
you you would get connected through your
supervisor my child ended up at the
hospital and i'm in the middle of the
floor i heard das answering the phone
i'm instantly devastated but i'm also
embarrassed
frustrated
aggravated that i had to get this phone
call like this in front of this woman
standing here in the midst of everybody
i ended up losing the job because
um when you're out you have to call in
and tell them kind of what's going on or
the reason for your being out
and at that time i couldn't even talk
without crying that really
kind of threw me off as a person burnout
isn't just something that happens at
work it's something that happens when
you're you know a domestic child care
provider and so if you're trying to do
both of those things people's mental
health suffers this stress is compounded
during the pandemic with one piece of
research stating that working women have
reported increased levels of depression
by 83
compared to 36 percent of working men
crucially this can impact a woman's
ability to progress in her career and
when women are underrepresented at work
companies are less incentivized to
provide them the support they need women
do a tremendous amount of unpaid labor
almost 86 of the household chores and
the child care rearing is done by women
and so you simply can't raise your hand
for that promotion you can't start that
business you can't take on that nursing
degree that you've always dreamed about
because you have so much happening at
home and this is why we have enormous
levels of poverty when it comes to women
of color because they're in low-paying
jobs and they're not getting the support
that they need you know to thrive so i
lost my job stopped paying rent we went
to
live in the shelter one of the things
that i did with a lot of my free time
was volunteer at church we wanted to
show the scriptures like so if people
didn't have their bible they could just
look up on the screen i figured out what
device to use and what program to run it
i had some help but a lot of it is me
running it and doing it and implementing
it
one of my friends she saw that i had a
good hold to technology
on her friend's recommendation tanya
soon applies and gets accepted into a
coding boot camp it's a program where
you don't pay upfront
but it's also like an unpaid thing so
there was no income coming from there so
i'm in pursuit struggling
things are moving very very quickly when
it comes to the coronavirus i'm stating
the obvious to everyone here
overheads
i had to shift my whole life to make
sure that i supported and covered my
children i have to leave early every day
from class i could get my daughter and
so that she could go into the shelter
we're told to stay indoors stay in place
but i couldn't i couldn't because i
still needed to do the classes and i was
having issues with the wi-fi they gave
me
so i would go to my church i think the
thing that broke so many of us and it
still breaks me now
is it didn't seem like anybody cared
it didn't seem like anybody was saying
gosh the moms
you know what are we gonna do because
this country doesn't function without us
but we just kind of
ate it up
and kept going
still many women found themselves
without any other options but to
persevere i had a lot of outside
stressors things there's a lot of
assignments that i wasn't able to
complete i get through the program at
pursuit i'm able to
move on to the next steps with my fellow
students in the class
and i'm not found job ready but i still
started applying to jobs just like
everybody else one of the alumni posted
a job position
i applied
i got hired at the not worldwide
when when i got the job i was crying
i was crying my boss nobody knew my
situation i didn't tell them like that's
not something you tell people when
you're interviewing no you're just going
to see confidence and competence that's
all you're going to see
while tanya found success in the end
this isn't always the case for other
working moms struggling to find their
work-life balance and there's still
plenty to be done from both the private
and public sectors to better support
working women and then we ask ourselves
you know why do we have a declining
birth rate well the reality is it's too
expensive to have kids and so it's not
that people don't want to have them it's
that they can't
a lot of companies pride themselves on
offering you know paid parental leave
some of these companies offer moms six
months dad three months why or when you
take when you're a guy and you actually
take the parental leave it's frowned
upon
we've seen companies like linkedin and
other tech companies kind of offering
alternative child care last summer for
example some companies offered summer
camps and then in the public sector
we've seen biden making a big push for
what we call soft infrastructure which
would be universal child care for
children's ages three and four as well
as child care subsidies for those from
zero to five the current child tax
credit that was passed during the
pandemic offers families up to 300 in
monthly payments per child as part of
her marshall plan for mom's proposal
reshma is calling for these credits to
be extended indefinitely among other
benefits making the child tax credit
permanent getting affordable child care
you know passing paid leave once for all
the second piece is really working you
know on the private sector and making
sure that we build a work environment
that works for parents offering parental
leave offering flexibility finally
getting equal pay for equal work
with so many things going on we have to
choose what our children over our jobs
like we're capable and if we're paid
enough for the value that we do bring we
can actually be able to do a bit more
even as congress makes moves towards
financial assistance for working mothers
there are also many other issues
preventing women from fully returning to
work in person
from sexual discrimination to harassment
to microaggression at the workplace
and then it's the men who have face time
with their bosses and are getting the
promotions and are being noticed if
employers really want to create a
greater culture of belonging it does
require addressing uh systems and and
that takes money covet has given us this
opportunity to look at our society and
say you know what i want to build it
back better right like this is broken
and it is okay to acknowledge it it's
not just for moms but it's for dads it's
for millennials who don't want to have
kids it's for everybody to be like
we are actually going to redesign the
workplace
so that it works
for us
and we have to recognize that we have a
once in a lifetime opportunity to do
that so while financial help and
flexible work accommodations can be
helpful in supporting the female
workforce the solution really begins at
home on a societal level we still have
inequality at home we're never going to
have a quality in the workplace we
didn't go through hell and back to say
exactly where we're at when this started
let's use this opportunity to fix things
for once let's finish this fight like
once and for all
you